it's to rwanda now where even though it
is not illegal to be gay or lesbian
lgbtq people have faced problems from
the society around them many say they
faced frequent discrimination but
against this backdrop one church has
decided to tread another path and open
its doors wide
sunday morning for most rwandans means
going to church and they're spoiled for
choice on where they can go to worship
but many lgbtq people say they didn't
feel welcome in rwanda's churches until
they found this one on the outskirts of
the capital kigali
i heard about this church a place that
accepts us unconditionally and accepts
anyone
and i jumped for joy because this is
something new in rwanda
at the moment i feel at home here
because this is the first time i can
freely sing
dance or talk with other people
who are not from the lgbtq community
christians from other churches criticize
us
they judge us because of our sexuality
saying we are cursed
in their eyes we will go to hell so it
is not easy for us to stay here
[Music]
the church's leadership made a conscious
effort to open up its membership which
is currently at about a hundred people
they say another five thousand from
around the country follow their
teachings online
the decision to integrate lgbtq people
into our churches came after we saw that
they were undesirable in any christian
church
we looked at the scriptures and saw that
they are acceptable people like us
that is why we welcomed these people of
god
other churches have distanced themselves
from that stance maintaining that true
christianity cannot be altered
behaviors like gay marriages and
homosexuality
and some of those those other things
they are then
portrayed as sinful behaviors
abominations actually for
as a matter of fact why
because every interdiction you find in
the bible is a protection for the
community
it's a common view in rwanda which has
over 15 000 churches
but with only one outlier providing the
unconditional welcome lgbtq christians
seek
[Music]
and to delve deeper into this i'm joined
by dr david ngong doxon gong is
originally from cameroon and is a
professor of religion and theology at
stillman college in tuscaloosa alabama
from where he joins us now welcome to dw
and news africa
it sounds almost counterintuitive
if you will a christian church being
open to
lgbtq people so many churches deny
followers who are open about their
sexuality is this an example uh
dachshund gong offer of a church
responding to changes in society to to a
new reality uh the issue of lgbtq
rights as you probably know is a very
hard
topic among the churches
in many afghan countries
and so this is just an example of a
church that is open
to welcoming those who have been
historically discriminated against yes
dr gong i'd like for you to take a
listen to reverend antoine rutai siri he
is from the anglican church of rwanda
and then i'll come back to you
it's not the culture that dictates
how the bible should be
it's the bible that should dictate how
the culture will be and i think that's
where people are making mistakes because
they say you should adjust the bible to
the new trends of culture it's the bible
that gives the right the the guidelines
it's the bible is like a lighthouse for
spiritual being at least for the
christians
so you've heard it there dachshund gong
clear condemnation from the anglican
church uh in africa
does the church actually practice what
it preaches and accept the bible in its
entirety as a quote lighthouse for the
faithful close quote
the correspondence that the
uh the preacher is saying that we have
to take the bible to shine the light in
society in a sense that is right
but also in a sense um the judge does
not always do that we see the church
all over the place when it comes to some
important issues
issues in society
but but when it comes to the issue of
lgbtq rights you know the church has
uh seems to go to the bible to say okay
this is what the bible is saying and
that we have to use the bible uh to
shine the light on society but the
church is not always
following what the church preaches when
it comes to that
it's often said dr gong that homophobia
in africa specifically is a relic of
colonialism
but what you've written is that there is
a purely african dynamic to to
homophobic attitudes on the continent
tell us a little bit more
about that and do you think things will
change
there is a kind of indigenous dynamic to
this uh but we should also notice that
many of the laws that are used against
lgbtq people in in many african
countries have colonial backgrounds um
but that that said
i i think there is also dynamic of
indigenous imagination indigenous ways
of thinking
that that feel into this so so i speak
of of the of the idea of community and
the survival of the community you know
that that depends a lot on
on procreation
you know um so so so there's the
reliance that a community cannot survive
if new new people are not created and so
um
often
homosexuality is is tied to the issue of
procreation so the argument is made uh
that lgbtq
lgbtq people
um inhibit procreation
wow interesting uh we could go on for a
very long time uh doctor and gone but we
must leave it here that's dr uh
david gong he's professor of religion at
and uh theology at stulman college in
tuscaloosa alabama we appreciate your
time sir thank you
thank you
you